[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport / c est sur tv 60,18 l'émission
ne pas manquer si vous êtes un passionné
de sport local c'est parti pour le
sommaire de ce magazine football c'était
le choc de cette avant dernière journée
du championnat de 2e division de
district montigny le bretonneux et où il
ya sous se sont séparés par un match nul
un résultat qui arrange les joueurs du
nord du département les détails dans
cette édition triathlon six courses
étaient organisées à versailles sur deux
jours pendant le versailles triathlon
festival parmi les rendez vous phare il
y avait le triathlon de la reine un
évènement 100% féminin reportage dans ce
magazine enfin notre module découverte
sera consacrée aujourd'hui aux
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste qui sont programmés au vélodrome
national de 50 ans et demi en octobre
nous avons rencontré des membres de
l'équipe de france pour parler de ce
sujet l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
on commence tout de suite par du
football un match au sommet était
programmé ce dimanche dans le
championnat de 2e division de district
monti le bretonneux deuxième recevait où
ils sont aux premiers à du classement
après un match accroché et plein de
rebondissements
les deux équipes se sont séparées par un
match nul qui arrange oui un montage de
lucas houdart
bâtiment qui est un tournant dans ce
championnat de d2 de district après cet
échec montigny le bretonneux deuxième du
classement ne gagnera pas ce dimanche 29
mai sur sa pelouse face au leader oiasso
et deux équipes se séparent sur un match
nul score final 1 partout très
difficilement diaries une très bonne
équipe à montigny-le-bretonneux gardien
même défensivement ils sont bons bas
depuis le début de saison sont là on
s'accroche avec eux pour la première la
deuxième place une déception puisque
au regard du scénario m'a surtout des
occasions de but avec les deux frappes
sur la barre et le penalty raté on avait
moyen de s'imposer après je trouve qu'on
a on a joué un peu avec le frein à main
on a eu du mal à se lâcher offensivement
on a dû faire mieux et on a laissé
toujours oui dans le match et ils
auraient pu même nous faire mal sur la
fin de match donc voilà c'est une
déception effectivement ce résultat
arrange ou qui reste premier du
classement à une journée de la fin de la
saison le club compte un point de plus
que montigny le bretonneux après 21
journées disputées
j'ai déjà énorme saison ils sont là
aussi les supporters la fin des gros
saison le coach il est là il nous
fallait juste un nul déjà pour la montée
c'est parfait on va valider ça
maintenant on va aller fêter ça comme il
se doit montigny le bretonneux aura
encore une infime chance de monter ce
dimanche 5 juin pour cela les inimités
se déplaceront sur le terrain de
l'équipe 3 de versailles de son côté où
se rendra à coignard pour clôturer la
saison
en tennis arthur rinderknecht a été
sorti au premier tour de roland garros
par alexander public le joueur
originaire de saint-germain-en-laye
blessé au poignet ces dernières semaines
s'est incliné en moins de deux heures
face au kazakh le score 6-2 6-4 6-4 lévy
noah jouera cette semaine le tournoi
challenger de poznan pour rebondir on va
maintenant parler à baseball de change
de france était organisée jeudi et
vendredi dernier entre le centre sportif
jean maréchal de montigny le bretonneux
et chartres cette 18e édition a regroupé
les huit meilleurs clubs de baseball de
france avec à la clé une place
qualificative pour la coupe d'europe de
baseball on écoute dylan michael joueur
et entraîneur aux couillard de montigny
le bretonneux sans rendez-vous qu'on
attend c'est de se maintenir parce qu'il
arrive souvent au mieux de la saison
donc il faut être prêt physiquement
à encaisser parce que sa demande de
match par jour en plus donc souvent
c'est difficile
[Musique]
réalisée physiquement la compétition a
finalement été remporté par les huskies
de rouen face à savigny 11,2 savini qui
avait éliminé les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux le vendredi on va maintenant
prendre la direction de versailles ce
week-end avait lieu le versailles
triathlon un festival six courses
étaient au programme pendant les deux
jours de compétition
parmi les rendez vous phare elle il y
avait le triathlon de la reine un
événement féminin un montage de xavier
jaglin à deux pas du château de
versailles plus de 2 100 féminine
participe ce dimanche 30 mai au
triathlon de la reine rendez vous
organisé à l'occasion de la 11e édition
du versailles triathlon festival un
cadre insolite qui séduit toujours les
sportifs c'est magnifique ça donne plus
solides bases et de bien courir de bien
nager parce que parce que c'est bon
alors on ait envie de toi aussi le cadre
est super sympa j'avoue là on n'a pas le
temps de regarder bâton fait la course
on est trop focus
au programme pour les filles 750 m de
natation dans la pièce d'eau des suisses
18 km de vélo sur le circuit nexter
systems et 5 km de course à pied pour
terminer sur un chemin
l'exigeant parce qu'il ya des dénivelés
parce que tout le début du parcours est
en montée parce que il ya pas mal de
relances sur le parcours vélo et à pied
c'est pas si simple non plus on est sur
un revêtement qui va être parfois un
petit peu un petit peu instable sur des
chemins et puis avec une bosse apprendre
à prendre deux fois c'est finalement en
bronze grâce et qui aura été la plus à
l'aise sur ce parcours ce jour là la
pensionnaire du club d'issy triathlon
s'impose grâce à un sprint dans la
dernière ligne droite son chrono une
heure 11 minutes et 11 secondes je suis
contente c'était une belle bataille avec
solène on va faire un bon truc par
équipes
camara qui vient d'arriver et je
comptais entité en bosnie le rendez vous
reviendra l'année prochaine pour une
douzième édition l'événement devrait une
nouvelle fois être organisée au mois de
mai
[Musique]
boxe à présent ce samedi 28 mai un gala
de boxe anglaise et est organisé au
complexe sportif europe à elancourt par
la team farruggia le club emblématique
du secteur au total une quinzaine de
combats amateurs étaient programmées
pendant la soirée on écoute l'entraîneur
du club temps guy farrugia
l'organisateur revient sur cet événement
on a fait pour honorer le club on va
dire pour redémarrer le club ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas organisé on en
refait un petit gala amateur
s'ils sont venus avec tous les anciens
donc où sont passés entraîneur et
on est resté en famille comme on dit
c'est des combats amateurs niveau
national quand l'art y en a qui viennent
de l'est de la france d'autres du nord
d'autre d'autres comme on appelle ça de
bretagne d'autres sont lancés c'est
vraiment nationale et bien sûr
d'ile-de-france aussi tous les résultats
sont à retrouver sur la page facebook du
club de la team farrugia on va
maintenant parler d'un sujet qui a
beaucoup fait parler en bulgarie
l'yvelinois à christian gomis a été
victime de racisme le 7 mai dernier
quand il joue avec son club du lokomotiv
plovdiv face à hard à christian gomis
qui est avec nous en plateau en sont
conscients bonsoir alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter les faits
tout d'abord c'était
le match qui s'est déroulé pendant les
playoffs pour les qualifications pour la
conférence ligue et nous étions menés 4
1 à 15 secondes du match nous ça nous
sommes revenus à 4 4 il restait un
dernier corner pour nous et dans la
surface de réparation comme dans chaque
match à se bousculer sa se pousser
pendant que ça se poussaient moi je suis
intervenu pour pour un peu calmé les
tensions entre un coéquipier à moi et de
joueurs petro ganeev en question ont du
coup quand je me suis intercalé entre
les deux il m'a dit en bulgare vatan
sale singe du coup moi je t'ai demandé
de répéter et mathieu et vatan sale
singe du coup ma première réaction ça a
été de t'appeler larbitre j'appelle
arbitres je vous l'expliqué que par
rapport aux faits qui marque ce qui
m'est reproché kim hee kim hee ji et du
coup l'arbitré m'a jean sérien faut
continuer à jouer sait rien ou du coup
j'ai laissé le
le match fini rester dans les arrêts de
jeu est resté une bonne poignée 30
secondes et du coup à la fin du match
j'ai été voir l'arbitré nouveau je lui
ai dit c'est normal ce qui se passe il
m'a dit s'il s'est rien passé le match
s'est fini c'est bon on y va et du coup
les arbitres et sont partis pendant que
le joueur elle a essayé de s'excuser à
deux reprises
la lors de leurs deux joueurs elle n'a
pas été sanctionné quoi ce que je trouve
pas ça normal
vous en voulez à qui dans cette histoire
j'en veux plus
à la fédération bulgare on va dire parce
que c'est des choses qui sont pas normal
ça a tellement été banalisée que
maintenant il ferme les yeux là dessus
du coup moi ce qui m'a un peu déplu
c'est que le joueur la semaine d'après
la rejouer normal quoi et avec les
instances du coup vous avez pu discuter
ou pas du tout pas du tout j'ai discuté
avec mon club mon club et mon quand même
soutenu ils ont fait un communiqué sur
leurs réseaux mais la fédération ils
n'ont pas agi quoi et quelle est votre
réaction par rapport à ça ça c'est une
réaction qui est enfin ma réaction n'a
pas été bien c'est normal parce que de
voir que j'arrive juste après en gros
pour moi je me dis que c'est devenu
normal quoi maintenant chaque joueur
peut se permettre d'insulter ou d'avoir
des reproches comme ça et il aura rien
du tout ce qui n'est pas normal quoi
c'est la première fois que vous
entendiez cela dans un stade c'est la
première fois qu'on me dit
personnellement comme ça mais sinon
venant des tribunes ont bu le calice
déjà entendu mais qu'on me dise
directement comme ça ça prouve encore
lesquels et la suite pour vous est ce
coup là les uns peut-être un peu plus
loin saisir des instants sont encore
d'autres instances où vous allez en
rester là malheureusement
malheureusement pas en rester là je vais
j'ai moi personnellement je veux pas en
rester là mais j'ai pas forcément le
choix parce que
s'il sanctionne pas enlacer la
fédération bulgare il sanctionne pas le
joueur c'est compliqué moi tout seul je
peux rien faire quoi vous avez pu
discuter avec petko ganev du coup avec
qui enfin qui vous à vous insulter sur
le terrain non après ça j'ai pas cherché
à discuter avec lui et lui l'a voulu
s'excuser discuter moi j'ai j'ai pas
voulu parce que là il n'a quand même
répéter s'il me le résultat première
fois ok ce serait quand même grave mais
le fait de me le répéter c'est bien pour
que le message soit passé du coup je
pense que vous allez continuer à jouer
en bulgarie non là actuellement mon
contrat il est terminée en fin de
contrat ge à la recherche de projets
d'un nouveau projet on va redonner leur
avenir quoi rien à voir avec ce qui
s'est passé sur le terrain n'ont rien à
voir est s'est passé sur le terrain
c'est juste que j'ai fait deux en plein
là-bas et du coup si tenté par un
nouveau projet pour franchir un autre
palier et est-ce que vous avez justement
ça sera ma dernière question est-ce que
vous avez des contacts avec d'autres
clubs
section secteur mes managers usons des
contacts un peu avec plusieurs clubs en
france notamment
qrm qui vireront en ligue 2 et le pau fc
aussi en ligue 2 sinon j'ai d'autres
pistes à l'étranger en turquie dans les
yvelines non je sais pas versailles par
exemple qu'un train de monter un nouveau
projet 7 qui pourrait qui pour elle est
peut-être un jour en ligue 2 ça pourrait
vous intéresser ça pourrait m'intéresser
dans le futur on va dire c'est un club
qui est en train de bien grandes guerres
donc je pense que dans les années à
venir dans un avenir proche a pour être
intéressant en tout cas vous cherchez un
club actuellement et vous est ouvert à
toutes les discussions si je comprends
bien c'est exactement on refuse aucune
offre on prend le temps de prendre le
temps de sacoches le message est passé
merci christian gomis merci à vous pour
votre témoignage on continuera
évidemment à vous suivre sur tv 78
toujours en football la ville de croissy
sur seine a eu la chance de recevoir
l'équipe de liverpool sur l'un de ses
terrains d'entraînement la ville avait
été retenu dans le plus grand des
secrets comme terrain d'entraînement
préparatoire à la finale de la ligue des
champions ce samedi 28 mai les raids se
sont finalement inclinés 1 0 face au
real madrid au stade de france 1 1 mo de
basket un camp d'entraînement mixte sera
programmée du 4 au 9 juillet et du 11 au
16 juillet à trappes au gymnase paul
maillet au rendez vous se clôturera par
un grand match de gala le 17 juillet les
destinées aux jeunes de 10 à 18 ans
l'écoutent l'organisateur de ce
rendez-vous michael mokongo l'idée c'est
vraiment de prendre 80 gamins 85 au
maximum parce que nous on ne veut pas
prendre énormément de gamin
prendre le temps de s'occuper de tous
ces enfants là de faire du qualitatif
de vraiment travailler sur tous les
fondamentaux du basket ball c'est sur le
travail d'un contraint de dribbles des
tirs 2 passes et le travail de jean
réduit en 3 3 ou 1 55 donc voila et puis
après autour de ça on veut on veut que
les enfants puissent profiter justement
des expériences des chaque personne qui
sont vraiment spécialisés dans leur
domaine dans notre module découverte
aujourd'hui direction le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
lieu des prochains championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste le rendez vous
soit reprogrammé en octobre dans la
structure nous avons rencontré des
membres de l'équipe de france sort
regardez
aujourd'hui pour notre module découverte
nous sommes au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est le
temple du cyclisme sur piste français
ici au mois d'octobre du 12 au 16
octobre il y aura les championnats du
monde sur piste
[Musique]
je suis aux côtés de deux sportifs de
l'équipe de france mathilde gros et
rayonner la halle alors mathilde de gros
on est ici sur votre lieu d'entraînement
est ce que c'est un lieu d'entraînement
performant pour vous les athlètes oui
tout à fait c'est un super un super
endroit une super piste et c'est vrai
que on a la chance de s'entraîner ici
tous les jours ça motive et surtout
quand on sait qu'il ya pas mal
d'événements qui vont pas tarder à
arriver sur cette piste donc franchement
c'est vraiment un lieu vraiment bien
pour nous rien c'est le lieu idéal on va
dire pour l'équipe de france c'est clair
que c'est un lieu idéal c'est un super
outil de travail pour prononcer travail
au quotidien et bon ça va être la piste
comme benzema tire de nombreux
événements donc c'est voilà c'est cool
de pouvoir s'entraîner ici il y aura de
grosses échéances dans les prochains
mois on vous en parlait quelques
instants amat il y aura notamment ces
championnats du monde qui se produiront
du 12 au 16 octobre prochain ici qu'est
ce que ça change pour vous
c'est vrai que ça nous pousse encore
plus ça
à performer parce que c'est vrai que ça
va être une belle répétition pour pour
les jeux de paris etc voilà c'est un
championnat du monde il ya des maillots
aller chercher des médailles donc il y
aura notre public notre famille nos amis
et du coup c'est vrai que ça nous pousse
encore plus à nous dépasser à nous
entraîner à être les meilleurs les
meilleurs clairement lors de cet
événement ça change quelque chose ou pas
pour vous que ce soit ici plutôt que
dans un lot de l'eau drôme
oui parce que déjà c'est en france donc
voilà automatiquement le public j'espère
va swinguer français donc voilà c'est
vraiment ça qui va changer je pense
aussi et oui l'atmosphère on la connaît
le vélodrome bon après c'est pas c'est
pas non plus une grosse différence par
rapport aux autres mais voilà c'est chez
nous donc c'est sûr qu'on aura du hacker
de perf et il aura public et voilà on
est très très motivés et vous connaissez
parfaitement cette piste exactement ont
parfaitement la piste et qu'est-ce que
vous visez vous sur ces championnats du
monde en octobre je pense qu'on vise
tous deux d'être le meilleur et d'aller
chercher un maximum de médailles de
maillots et voilà ça sera l'événement
majeur de l'année ce sera en france chez
nous devant nos amis notre famille et
voilà c'est je pense que chaque athlète
dans n'importe quelle discipline
on aura tous à coeur d'aller chercher le
meilleur de nous-mêmes et de est de
ramener la plus belle des médailles
médaille quoi qu'il arrive j'espère est
pour vous ryan cherche un médaille d'or
je pense pour ce championnat ça va être
vraiment c'est vrai de
concrétiser douala on a pu l'occasion de
faire du podium des deux des 3e et
championne du monde là ça va être
vraiment d'essayer d'élever notre niveau
un premier temps et deuxième m'a
vraiment d'aller chercher la pub et des
ménages c'est l'occasion aussi de se
tester en vue des jo de 2024 qui se
produiront ici en 2024 est ce que c'est
une première étape importante pour vous
oui c'est une première étape très
importante parce que hormis que ce soit
comme vous dites une première étape
c'est un championnat du monde et on
n'aura que deux avants avant les jeux de
paris est et c'est vrai que un
championnat du monde il ya énormément
bas de pression dans jeu et du coup le
but ça va être vraiment de rester
focalisé sur sur nous-mêmes et de donner
le meilleur et en plus c'est vrai
qu'avec les jeux de paris dans deux ans
ça va nous permettre de prendre des
repères ça ouais ça va être comme un
très bon entraînement plus plus en vue
de paris
une répétition générale c'est sa réelle
c'est ça une bonne répétition pour les
jeux de paris voilà pour l'ambiance le
public la pression l'engouement aussi
qui a glacé pas pile poil 2 en avant ses
lames ce sera la même piste le même
environnement
et donc voilà ça va vraiment être une
une répétition et surtout un bon
tremplin pour
pouvoir être propulsé un peu sur les
premières places et pouvoir essayer de
le garder jusqu'au bout quelle est la
différence entre un championnat du monde
et les jeux olympiques
je sommes impliqués tous les quatre ans
et champion du monde c'est tous les ans
pour moi la plus grande différence donc
que ces voiles assez rare ces jeux
olympiques c'est vraiment pour notre
sport il ya pas plus haut y a pas plus
haut il n'y a pas de cap à d'autres lits
ou autre chose c'est vraiment les jeux
olympiques on s'entraîne pour ça on vit
pour ça on dort pour ça et c'est que les
jeux olympiques simplement et on est
d'accord c'est à peu près les mêmes
athlètes qui seront présents en octobre
oui oui tout à fait ce sera pratiquement
les mêmes athlètes mais c'est vrai que
les jeux comme un terreau ryan c'est
vraiment et 9,1 un monde un événement
totalement différent et déjà le fait que
ça se produise que tous les 4 ans et et
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de différent mais mais grâce à ce
championnat du monde à saint quentin
dans quelques mois on va pouvoir déjà
se prendre des repères pour pour les
jeux parce que ce sera la même piste là
même la même ambiance et ce sera les
mêmes personnes comme vous l'avez dit
donc faudra vraiment rester dans ce
schéma là vous y pensez vous déjà aux
jeux olympiques on y pense tous parce
que voilà ce sera à paris et on voit
comment commence à prendre de l'ampleur
petit à petit et c'est vrai que comme a
dit ryan on vit clairement pour ça mais
c'est vrai que on y pense mais avant il
ya tellement de choses tellement de
compétition même avant les mondiaux
également c'est vrai qu'il faut voilà
faire pas pas vraiment prendre les
compétitions les unes après les autres
pour pas brûler certaines étapes et pour
être performant le jour j et vous rien
ne vous y pensez oui évidemment c'est
mon objectif numéro 1 tasse on laissait
les jeux olympiques ça va passer par
beaucoup d'entraînement des compétitions
des compétitions avant mais oui c'est
clairement
le graal quoi nograles c'est vraiment
pour ça si je pourrai rien faire pendant
quatre ans mais de champion olympique
jérémy tout de suite quoi
merci à tous les deux et on suivra
évidemment avec attention vos
performances au mois d'octobre ici sur
ce vélo tome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
[Musique]
après les athlètes de l'équipe de france
je suis avec le coach erman alors herman
comment ça se passe ici l'entraînement à
quelques mois de cette échéance des
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste bah ça se passerait bien ça fait
déjà plusieurs mois qu'on a repris on a
eu la période d'après jeu qui a été
assez court parce qu'on avait un cheval
du monde en france dans l'après jeux
très vite on s'est remis au travail
parce que là l'olympia des courtes
jusqu'à 2024 et donc là le plein face de
travailler et voilà avec 50,1 en ligne
de mire pour les 2022 qui est notre
grosse échéance pour pour nous coacher
et ayant des coureurs non voilà donc on
se prépare activement pour pour les jeux
parce que ça reste comme notre finalité
mais voilà c'était cette étape de
saint-quentin octobre 2022 ça reste
hyper important pour nous devant notre
public ça va être une super répétition
donc actuellement dans une grosse phase
de travail et comment vous travaillez
justement au quotidien ici mal quotidien
voilà on a une super esprit structure ou
et forcément les mises en limite de
super conditions on a voilà tout à
disposition un vélodrome voilà de
exceptionnel qui sera théâtre des jeux
olympiques en 2024 voilà tout la salle
de musculation fera tout pour toi tout
ce qui est mis en place pour pour nous
et qui nous qui va nous permettre de
réussir est ce qu'on peut dire que les
athlètes sont chouchoutés ici bas on
essaie alors on essaye de ne pas trop
pour les mettre dans le confort mais
voilà on recrée sont mis dans des bonnes
conditions suffisant en tout cas pour
performer donc voilà en tout cas on
essaye d'être on est tous dans le même
bateau et voilà on sait on sait on voit
on veut aller on a un objectif c'est
faire les médailles d'or aux jo de paris
et donc voilà donc on travaille dur pour
réussir les championnats du monde c'est
justement une étape importante pour
préparer ces jo de 2024 c'est hyper
important parce qu'on sait aussi chaque
olympiade le niveau monte
on imagine aussi sq le niveau qui va
falloir atteindre en 2024 et c'est vrai
que à la maison avec voilà nos
supporters
c'est hyper important de faire une
grosse performance alors il ya les
résultats va aller mais les médailles
les maillots et qu'on espère faire avec
notre collectif est aussi des
performances chronométriques
importante en tout cas dans sur la route
qui nous mène à paris 2004 est ce que
vous voulez marquer les esprits avec ces
championnats du monde qui seront
organisées ici en octobre est ce que
vous voulez réussir un peu dans tous les
domaines pour dire voilà la france est
là on est prêts on vous attend on a une
feuille de route qui nous mène jusqu'à
2024 c'est sûr que
c'est important aussi un point de vue
aussi mentales pour les athlètes pour
nous de réussir cette étape donc oui
tout est fait pour réussir
je pense que tout va bien se passer
parce que tout le monde bosse bien on a
des coureurs à potentiel donc voilà on
c'est important et puis bien sûr envoyer
aussi un signe adversaire qu'il va
falloir compter sur nous en 2024 mais
voilà on sait aussi qu'on a des cours à
potentiel on croise il ya rarement des
surprises on se connaît tous voilà on
fait partie si les décors et les nations
fortes
donc voilà on se sera un moment
important en tout cas pour pour 2024 en
vue 2004 il faut faire attention on peut
être pas partir trop tôt
oui oui mais toute façon voilà notre
calendrier notre échéancier il est déjà
fait jusqu'à 2024 on a aussi la sur
l'année 2022 va concentrer aussi nos
efforts pour être performant au mois
d'octobre c'est pour ça que voilà je le
dis c'est vraiment une étape qui est
quand même très importante on va aller
ailleurs à deux ans des jeux donc voilà
aussi beaucoup de phases de travail
actuellement parce qu'après on va
rentrer très rapidement de la phase de
qualification olympique donc voilà on
on sait où on va tout et tout un peu
balisé donc maintenant il va falloir
être présent le jour j comment vous la
sentez cette équipe de france allez
assez jeune mais on a l'impression que
ces jeunes gagnent en expérience au fur
et à mesure ouais ouais bon déjà on sort
d'une olympiade où on avait beaucoup de
faux positifs des jeunes émerger c'est
vrai que là d'autres collectifs ont eu
22 on a 23 ans de moyenne d'âge donc
voilà on va arriver sur du 25 au moment
des jeux olympiques voilà on est quand
même sur 25 ans nous montre quoi pour le
sprint en pleine force de l'âge avec de
l'expérience avec plusieurs qui ont soit
été médaillés soit une participation aux
jeux olympiques voilà tout ça plus le
fait avoir cette motivation
supplémentaire parce que c'est les jeux
en france voilà tout est réuni pour que
ça se passe bien vous avez déjà une idée
du nombre de médailles que vous pourriez
rapporte à la france voilà des idées
alors je vous dirai pas là tout de suite
les annoncé mais bien évidemment dans
toutes les disciplines dans lesquelles
vont être alignés aux autres qu'on va se
qualifier je pense qu'on aura des
chances de remporter l'or donc bien
vivant la concurrence il ya de plus en
plus de version il ya plus en plus de
densité dans nos disciplines mais voilà
en tout cas on aura les armes pour se
battre et pour réussir la question quel
est votre plus grand rêve herman plus
grand est bienvenue c'est aller chercher
l'or olympique à l'art bien évidemment
plusieurs médailles d'or si on parle de
rêve après voilà même si on rafle pas
toutes les médailles d'or ça n'empêchera
pas que le bilan puisse plus être bon en
tout cas on se donne les moyens de
réussir avec la fédération voilà il ya
énormément de moyens qui sont investis
moyens humains moyens financiers et donc
voilà avec toutes ces aides là et puis
voilà c'est cet événement qui qui arrive
forcément pour les athlètes une seule
fois dans une vie les jumeaux en france
voilà on espère vraiment qu'on va
pouvoir faire un super bilan est marqué
l'histoire aussi notre sport merci
beaucoup et on vous le souhaite merci
[Musique]
c'est reparti
vous l'avez compris ces championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste seront un
événement ici au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines on va écouter
justement nicolas andré qui travaille à
la fédération française de cyclisme
c'est notre interview express
[Applaudissements]
on l'espère 5000 places environ à 6 sur
cinq jours 25000 spectateurs attendus en
2015 il était plein on espère avoir le
même succès pour encourager les équipes
de france sur le chemin olympique
[Musique]
2 il ya différents tarifs il ya des
tarifs en semaine entre 30 et 40 euros
pour venir sur les jours de semaine
mercredi jeudi vendredi
on est à environ 10 euros de plus sur
les fourchettes pour samedi et dimanche
et on a aussi un pass 5 jours située
entre 80 et 200 euros suivant où est la
place située c'est une vente à la place
et on est une offre spécialement pour
les saint quentinois donc les 12
communes de l'agglomération ont une
offre avantageuse et aussi les licenciés
de la ffsa
oui il y aura forcément du spectacle
avec des équipes de france gonflée à
bloc
qui sont en train de travailler leur
parcours olympique qui ont à coeur de
briller non seulement je mets des les
championnats du monde à maillot arc en
ciel c'est très important dans une
carrière c'est aussi une confiance
accrue en vue des jeux et nous entre
guillemets on essayait de leur offrir le
plus beau théâtre et c'est aussi notre
championnat du monde faire une belle
organisation et avoir des français sur
la plus haute marche du podium
en 2015 l'équipe de france avait
remportée à sept médailles dont 5 en or
l'équipe de france espère faire encore
mieux en octobre prochain
c'est la fin cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]